c'est sympa on le fait de temps en temps
c'est la deuxième fois seulement cette
année on a écrit moi j'ai écrit mon
livre il ya un an on a fait peu de
dédicaces avec la crise est au coeur
présentateur emblématique du journal de
13 heures jean-pierre pernaut était ce
samedi 13 novembre dans la librairie le
bain d'encre aux chaînés rocancourt pour
une séance de dédicaces de quoi rendre
nostalgique certains visiteurs c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait découvrir des
régions à mes parents et pendant leurs
vacances il allait donc dans les régions
qu'ils ont découvert grâce où j'étais
monsieur pernaut en fait ça fait depuis
des années bah quoi on le regarde à la
télé le tf 1 est donc pour nous c'est
c'est un monsieur sacré journalistes
avec lui nathalie marquay-pernaut sa
femme elle présentait son nouveau livre
moi j'y crois je crois à mésanges à mes
guides je fais des rêves prémonitoires
donc je peux que y croit dans mon livre
je raconte aussi que jamais eu la date
de la mort du frère de jean-pierre donc
grâce à moi il a pu lui dire un dernier
adieu tient un livre étonnant pour une
personnalité connue parce que les gens
n'osent pas parler de ces des rapports
avec l'au delà des prémonitions des
pressentiments des anges etc et elle
raconte tout ce qu'elle vit au quotidien
habitant dans les yvelines le couple est
familier de sa librairie locale je
vienne dans un temps ici jamais j'aime
bien
pas assez souvent malheureusement mais
c'est vrai que quand j'avais payé les
stylos à acheter pour mes enfants c'est
toujours ici que je veux je viens c'est
donc naturellement que l'ancienne miss
france 1987 est venu rencontrer ses
lecteurs pour faire découvrir son
quatrième ouvrage